This video is brought to you by innovative language,
the creators of Norwegian class one Oh one and Danish class one Oh one
innovative language courses,
or one of my favorite ways to start learning a new language online,
click the link in the description for a free lifetime account to give it a try.
Hello, everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel. And my name is Johansson.
Today.
We're going to compare Danish and Norwegian specifically one of the two official
forms of Norwegian boot mall due to the union of Denmark and Norway,
which lasted for centuries mall is largely based on the Danish spoken by the
upper classes and Norway. During that time,
they initially book mall are in large part the same with some slight differences
in grammar and spelling, some different vocabulary, words and usage,
and more than anything else, differences in pronunciation.
Danish is famous for being difficult to understand because of the tendency to
slur and delete sounds that are more clearly pronounced in Norwegian to be
clear,
Norwegian has no official pronunciation and all accents are considered correct,
but the pronunciation,
the accent of the capital Oslo serves as a defacto standard.
Let's compare some basic vocabulary and see where the differences lie.
Especially in pronunciation in Norwegian,
we have this word meaning weird or funny in Danish
means pleasant. Also notice the difference in the R sound in Norwegian.
It's an alveolar trill in Danish.
It's a uvular fricative or approximate at the beginning of the word.
And at the end of the word, it's silent, but in its place,
we can hear stew the glottal stop or creaky voice that appears in some
Danish words, it's represented in IPA transcription by this symbol,
Norwegian doesn't have this feature,
but instead has distinctions in pitch accent.
Both of these words mean knife.
Can you, in both words.
The combination K N is pronounced the same,
but in Norwegian I V is pronounced Eve while in Danish.
It's a diphthong you. And again,
the word ends in a global stop or laryngeal cricket.
The voice,
these words mean dress shoe LA Jolla.
There's a subtle difference in the sound that KJ represents in either language
in Norwegian it's, a voiceless palatal fricative while in Danish.
It's cute in Danish.
It's a cluster of two sounds K followed by. Yeah,
because the second sound is palatal.
It ends up sounding somewhat similar to the Norwegian sound,
which is also palatal.
These words mean Deere in Norwegian and in Danish.
Notice the difference in the initial consonant in Danish cook and go can appear
before a front vowel, but a Norwegian. They can't. So the diagraphs,
GJ and KJ are used to represent the different consonant.
Sounds also notice the silence are in the Danish word.
These words mean shirt in Norwegian.
Sure. And in Danish.
Again,
notice the difference in the initial consonant this time represented by SKJ
in Norwegian it's HSA while in Dana skin.
There's also a difference in the vowel sound in Norwegian. It's more like, Ooh,
while in Danish, it's more like,
or because the Danish are after a vowel is pronounced as a vowel itself.
These words mean ship in Norwegian.
Shi, and in Danish scheme.
Notice that in the Norwegian word,
S K represents HSA while in the Danish word,
it represents SCA silent G occurs in both languages,
sometimes in the same context. And sometimes in different contexts,
these two words are cognates and both feature a silent G in Norwegian
dial-in meaning delicious or lovely. And in Danish daily,
meaning wonderful or lovely, and sometimes delicious.
Also notice the slightly different spelling.
There are lots of little spelling differences like this between Danish and
Norwegian while delicious is a primary meaning of the Norwegian word in
Danish. It's more common meaning as wonderful or lovely.
These words mean book in Norwegian.
And a Danish.
Notice the final K in the Norwegian word and the G in the Danish word in
Danish, the final G is silent. The vowel represented by Oh,
is also different in Norwegian. It's more like, Ooh, well in Danish,
it's more like all,
but here the OMG together actually form a diphthong these
words mean guest or visitor in Norwegian.
And in Danish. Yes.
Notice the difference at the beginning of the words in Norwegian G is silent
before J so it's simply you while in Danish.
It's like I said before in Danish, go can come before a front vowel,
but in Norwegian at camp,
these words mean evening in Norwegian.
And in Danish often.
In Norwegian, often is also used,
but it's less commonly used than Cavell and a little more old fashioned.
And in Danish, uh, cognitive, the Norwegian word exists,
but it's old fashioned and not used much anymore.
These words mean page or side in Norwegian.
See the ad in Danish CU.
While these words look the same on paper,
the Danish pronunciation has the soft D and the final vowel vanishes
CU.
Now let's look at some sentences in both languages and see how different they
are. If you've seen my previous video on Norwegian,
you may recognize these sentences.
These sentences mean I want to eat in Norwegian visa and
in Danish, that was BS.
We can see two sentences that are identical on paper. Of course,
there are some slight differences in pronunciation,
but nothing really worth pointing out. Here's another sentence,
meaning I haven't eaten anything today in Norwegian
and in Danish. Here's another sentence.
That's very similar on paper with some differences in pronunciation and one word
with a slightly different form in either language in Norwegian.
There's the neutral singular of newsroom in Danish.
There's the neutral singular of node.
Notice how the negation word is pronounced differently in either language in
Norwegian and in Danish, IGA in Norwegian,
the double K represents a long continent in Danish [inaudible] and
CA are voiced when doubled the double letter does not indicate a long consonant
in Danish.
Also notice the difference in pronunciation of this word in Norwegian
and in Danish. The date in Norwegian,
the long a vowel is pronounced, ah, while in Danish,
it's pronounced a and in Norwegian,
the G is pronounced as good while in Danish,
a final G like this is silent or an approximate. That's almost silent,
like a slight sound, another sentence,
meaning they like to drive fast cars in Norwegian
[inaudible] and in Danish,
[inaudible] first noticed the different ways of expressing like in the two
languages in Norwegian there's li in Danish,
like is expressed with the phrase, why does it include Kuna?
Which means can, or able to, well, even though now the whole phrase just means,
like, it originated with the meaning of able to bear something,
meaning you're able to handle it or deal with it. Like it's not too bad.
Next notice the different form of the infinitive particle like two in English
and notice the different spelling and pronunciation of the verb,
meaning to drive.
Okay.
Next we see different adjectives,
meaning fast in Norwegian and in Danish hoodie.
The word.
Does exist in Danish,
but it's very old fashioned to use it with the meaning of fast,
but it's still often used with the meaning of healthy,
who also exists in Norwegian as a synonym of Rusk.
Another sentence,
meaning crime is increasing due to high unemployment in Norwegian
[inaudible] and in Danish.
[inaudible] the main difference in this pair of sentences is a difference in
vocabulary preference. For example, these words,
which are the present tense forms of the verbs, meaning to increase,
there is a cognate of.
Yeah. In Danish ish, but the usual word would be steer.
And there's a cognitive.
Steer in Norwegian. Steve.
Steve.
See basically the same phrase,
meaning due to literally on ground of ground as in reason.
But there's a difference in pronunciation between these words here.
Region Gideon and in Danish in the North.
Region where the U represents an oo sound. But in Danish, the,
you can be pronounced differently after the uvular are more like all.
And while the Norwegian word ends in a long continent,
the Danish word ends in followed by a glottal stop or creaky voice.
The D is silent after N in this word, the F is silent.
And at the end of the Danish word for unemployment, there's a soft D.
Let's examine.
One final pair of sentences.
These sentences mean falling in love is common among young people in Norwegian
flooded out of all liberal and in Danish.
[Inaudible] in this lab.
Per of sentences. Again,
we see the same sentence structure with some different vocabulary preference,
the words for common or different notice, the different spellings of the words,
meaning.
Mung plum plant.
And again,
D is silent after N so we don't really hear a difference in the continents here.
The main difference here is in the quality of the a vowel notice that the terms
for young people are somewhat different.
There is a word for young people in Danish.
That's more similar to the Norwegian. One Udon though,
that word is pretty old fashioned in Danish.
As you.
Can see, Norwegian and Danish are very similar on paper,
but end up sounding quite different when they're spoken.
They're different enough to be considered different languages,
but they're close enough that speakers of either language can read the other one
without much trouble.
It seems to me that speakers of either language could learn to understand the
other one,
as it's naturally spoken by learning the features of the other languages,
phonology, and then getting lots of exposure to it. Indeed,
people who move from one country to the other do just that and also learn to
make their own speech more intelligible to speakers of the other language,
by speaking, more clearly or more slowly, but a lot of Norwegians and Danes,
as well as Swedes tell me that they just speak English with each other instead.
And that brings me to the question of the day to speakers of Norwegian and
Danish and Swedes, too. If you want to jump in,
do you think learning to understand each other and communicate in your
respective languages is a useful skill,
or do you think it's better to simply use English as many people do and other
people, what do you think about the differences between Danish and boot mall?
Do they genuinely seem like different languages to you?
If you're excited to learn more Norwegian or Danish, then check out Lang
focused.com/class or Lang focused.com/danish class.
Innovative language courses are among the most popular online courses in the
world. And for good reason,
they are very extensive courses with literally hundreds of lessons for learners
of any level. Their core feature is podcast style, audio lessons,
which is great for people who like to learn using audio materials.
And for people who want to learn on the go, I'm a member of several class,
one Oh one and pod one Oh one courses.
And I use them to improve my listening comprehension and to improve my
pronunciation through shadowing, the dialogues and monologues,
but class one Oh one and pod one Oh one courses offer more than just audio
lessons.
They also have lots of video lessons and excellent tools like downloadable
transcripts and lesson notes, spaced repetition, flashcards,
and quizzes features like these help you to review and solidify what you learn
in each lesson so that you keep building upon what you've learned and create a
strong foundation in the language class one Oh one and pod one-on-one lessons
are compact and easy to complete in a single sitting,
but don't just move on to the next lesson and forget about the previous one.
The review tools are there to help solidify what you've learned.
It would be a mistake to breeze through all the lessons too quickly without
using all of those extra review features.
I've never learned a language using only an innovative language course,
but I'm a member of several of their sites.
And I regularly use them as part of my study program. Lots of content is free,
including all new lessons, which are free for the first couple of weeks.
And then if you want access to all the archived content,
you can upgrade to a paid account.
I really recommend you check out innovative language courses,
whether for Norwegian Danish or one of 32 other languages,
they offer click the link in the description to get a free lifetime account.
I also want to give a big shout out to all the Lang focus, Patrion supporters,
especially the top tier patrons whose names are on the screen. Check out
patrion.com/lang focus and check out the benefits of the various tiers and to
everyone. Thank you for watching and have a nice day.